it's that sweet spot of enjoying life
and trying really really hard at it at
the same time it's essentially what we
all strive for and there are these
incredible cases throughout history
famous scientists Like Richard Fineman
Nobel Prize winner he's most famous for
Bongo drumming naked on the roof of
Caltech and he became an amazing artist
in his 60s and he developed all sorts of
other skills he always had this
childlike way of looking at the world he
never let himself get stuck in his ways
never became a kudin and a remarkable
man and that's something that I but you
come away with nothing else I encourage
you to do that you want your brain to
change stay light stay loose but give it
everything you've got